you post a lot of pictures of your dog
and a lot of people do this on Instagram
but yours are I would say more
entertaining than most look at this
first of all that's him after three
scotches looks like a drunk Winston
Churchill watching a football game there
you go okay let's see another one
just curious oh yeah he's your dog okay
by the way can I get some quieter for
your dogs all right he's 16 and his dong
he's been like that since he was a baby
does it ever go in his tongue no it's
always out it's too big for his mouth I
had him checked yeah doctor just said
there's no issue here he just his tongue
is just too big for his mouth and I was
like okay well because this one I
thought was posed but you say it's not
no you got no his tongue gets super dry
and my stepson likes Cheerios and
there's Cheerios I guess on the couch
and his tongue yeah he passed out eating
a cheerio and it stuck to his tongue I
think that the cheerio was just on the
couch right tongue just sort of fell
into it that's what happened
all right so in a way he's like a
walking lint he's gonna pick up all
kinds of stuff yeah you're gonna find
things that you lost years ago I don't
have to clean No
you